SECURITY THREATS.
HE WILL ASSESS THE RISKS ONCE
CONFIRMED AS THE NEXT NSA
DIRECTOR.
>> Bret: THE HEAD OF
U.S. PACIFIC COMMAND ON
CAPITOL HILL SAID TODAY THERE
ARE NO LIMITED PREEMPTIVE
MILITARY OPTIONS WHEN IT COMES
TO DEALING WITH NORTH KOREA.
ADMIRAL TERRY HARRIS SCOFFED
WHEN ASKED ABOUT A SO-CALLED
BLOODY NOSE STRATEGY AGAINST
NORTH KOREA.
HERE IS JENNIFER GRIFFIN.
>> NORTH KOREA REMAINS OUR MOST
URGENT SECURITY THREATS.
>> U.S. MILITARY CONTINUING TO
PLACE MAXIMUM PRESSURE ON
NORTH KOREA, AS DIPLOMATS
SCRAMBLE TO FIND A PLACE FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND KIM JONG UN
TO MEET.
ON CAPITOL HILL, THE TOP U.S.
COMMANDER IN THE PACIFIC
DOWNPLAYED TALK OF LIMITED U.S.
MILITARY OPTIONS.
>> WE HAVE NO BLOODY NOSE
STRATEGY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
THE PRESS HAVE RUN WITH IT.
WE HAVE TO BE READY TO DO THE
WHOLE THING.
WE ARE READY TO DO THE WHOLE
THING IF ORDERED BY THE
PRESIDENT.
>> NORTH KOREA'S FOREIGN
MINISTER STOPPED IN BEIJING.
>> SWEDEN COULD BE ONE OPTION.
THEN WE HAVE THE DMZ ZONE WHICH
IS THAT MORE LIKELY OPTION.
KIM JONG UN, WILL HE BE WILLING
TO TRAVEL?
HIS FATHER AND GRANDFATHER WERE
NOT WILLING TO.
>> NEITHER KIM JONG UN NOR
NORTH KOREA HAVE PUBLICLY
ACKNOWLEDGED THE OFFER TO TALK.
>> WE CAN'T BE OVERLY OPTIMISTIC
ON OUTCOMES.
WE HAVE TO SEE WHERE IT GOES.
>> THE U.S. MILITARY IS MOVING
FORWARD WITH PLANNED MILITARY
EXERCISES WITH SOUTH KOREA IN
TWO WEEKS.
>> I DON'T THINK THIS YEAR WILL
BE ANY DIFFERENT THAN THOSE THAT
HAVE OCCURRED IN THE PAST.
>> ADMIRAL HARRIS ADDED THAT THE
U.S. UNDERESTIMATED THE
INTENTIONS OF CHINA WHO NOW HAS
HYPERSONIC WEAPONS AND A LEADER
WHO COULD RULE FOR DECADES.
>> CHINA'S INTENT IS CRYSTAL
CLEAR AND WE IGNORE IT AT OUR
PERIL.
>> THE CHINESE CONSIDER ADMIRAL
HARRIS A HARD-LINER, EVEN
QUESTIONING WHETHER HIS TOUGH
STANCE IN THE SOUTH CHINA SEA IS
BECAUSE HIS MOTHER IS JAPANESE.
BRET, WHEN IT COMES TO